all right so we're talking about basic
joke use in Aikido
there's tons of videos out there right
now talking about the forms or Coty's
and Sebu tea all kinds of stuff but I
feel that there's some areas that are
not really getting talked about that we
should be talking about and as the Act
you know community is asking how is I
could work what's it good at you really
should be looking towards weapons
practice if you don't understand weapons
then it's really kind of impossible to
understand the rest of Aikido so right
now we're gonna look at the guide sheet
and what the guy's huge there's several
guys huges and Ike you know so there's
the the gate on guy's huge the Jo dong
guy's huge the hostel guy's huge
so these are all turnover strikes though
the weapon gets turned over for a reason
a lot of people I think don't really
understand why there is a turnover what
a turnover would would be used for I'll
give you a couple examples right now
with the gate on and Joe Don guy's huge
so if I line up and ski come on with
Josh josh is gonna be in Joe come on as
I come in he's gonna use a defense so as
I come into not high up into the side
okay now my weapons knocked over here if
I'm trying to use this in it's really
not very useful to me right so it takes
a lot of force to bring it back online
if he's attacking me in the middle of
all that's bad news so instead what I
can do is let the weapons turnover and
use the other side so if we're ski in
and out you look like this okay as this
guy hits my weapon I allow it to go
sucking up the slack and this gives me a
again engage so I'm allowing the weapon
to turnovers this is what all the guys
you just do they allow the other side to
turn over and kick so there's our Gannon
guys we do that same thing with the
Geoghan guys turn it over up high so
then anytime that my weapons contacted I
can use the guy's huge movements to
defend myself now if we were to look at
the hustle guys Josh goes into Khimki my
for me so we were looking at something
like a hot I'm in right so josh is gonna
cut I see the weapon and hit me in the
head when he does this
by trying to get just the tip back I'm
gonna be very slow trying to get this
back to defend myself after you hit it
so instead I can use the ha so to come
in and hit with the backside if I was
slower than that I could use the hustle
super right coming up high so the
hustle guys sets me up from any kind of
action like this all the way to a bungee
no kamae over come on I'm super slow I
could still use it that way and if you
follow up with the hustle Gatien series
it's teaching us after we did that then
what kind of strikes did we develop next
so when you look at these the guys
series I think a lot of us aren't
focusing on the utility of them the guy
shoots is a very useful functional
utility pull is what I want to say
uh-huh strike that allows you to turn
the weapon right over right so when my
weapon gets hit it allows me to turn it
over and use the other side you can do
this with beginning guys the hostile
guys toward the jodan guys there they
all work really nice like this so these
are the guys shoot striking series for
the joke